la idea de la vida media de la vida
media es muy útil vida media cuando
nosotros tenemos unidades de tiempo que
tienen que ver con múltiplos de la vida
media por ejemplo si nosotros tenemos a
en el tiempo igual a cero bueno pues en
el tiempo igual a cero nosotros tenemos
el 100 por ciento de nuestra substancia
el 100 por ciento pero nosotros también
podemos tener a el tiempo igual a una
vida media cuando nosotros tenemos una
vida media ha pasado una vida media
bueno pues entonces solamente nos queda
la mitad de la sustancia el 50% y
después de que pase otra vida media
después de dos vidas medias
bueno pues solamente nos vamos a quedar
con la mitad de la mitad es decir el 25%
y así podemos seguir y seguir y seguir y
bueno es que si por ejemplo yo te digo
que han pasado tres vidas medias y
digamos que hablamos del carbono-14 que
aproximadamente esta cantidad de tiempo
serían
quince mil años entonces de una manera
exacta podemos decir cuánto carbono-14
nos queda es decir qué porcentaje de
carbono 14 nos va a quedar de la
cantidad inicial y es más el carbono 14
que tenemos todavía no ha decaído al
nitrógeno 14 todavía no ahora hasta aquí
va bien todo vamos bien sin embargo esto
no nos quita la duda de qué es lo que va
a pasar si nosotros pensamos en otro
tipo de cantidades de tiempo por ejemplo
nosotros pensamos que es lo que va a
pasar después de medio año o después de
media vida media o tal vez después de
diez minutos o un millón de años y tal
si nosotros queremos una función general
que nos diga cuál es la cantidad déjame
ponerlo así cuál va a ser nuestra
cantidad que nos va a quedar de esta
sustancia que está decayendo después de
un cierto tiempo esto estaría genial y
de hecho es justo lo que vamos a ver en
este vídeo y bueno para esto vamos a
ocupar un poco del conocimiento de
matemáticas
realmente no va a ser muy complicado y
más si ya tomaste el primer curso de
cálculo de hecho esta es una clara
aplicación del primer curso de cálculo
así que recordemos o vamos a hablar un
poco sobre la tasa de cambio o lo
podremos pensar como la probabilidad del
número de partículas que está cambiando
en un tiempo dado es decir en lo que nos
queremos fijar es en cómo cambia o cuál
es la diferencia entre la cantidad del
número de partículas entre el número de
partículas entre un cambio muy pero muy
pero muy pequeño de tiempo lo que me voy
a fijar es cómo cambia esta cantidad con
respecto a un cambio en el tiempo y
bueno de que va a depender esta
expresión que tengo aquí es decir que si
aquí tenemos a la función de la cantidad
de partículas que tenemos con respecto
al tiempo aquí entonces estamos
expresando la tasa de cambio y bueno lo
primero que quiero que te des cuenta es
que este va a tener un valor negativo y
bueno es que también podemos decir que
este sería
hablamos por ejemplo del crecimiento del
compuesto si hablamos del crecimiento
del compuesto este sería positivo y
dependería de que tanto compuesto
tenemos bien y para explicar esto vamos
a intentar hacerlo un poco más intuitivo
imagínate que aquí tengo a 1 por 10 1
por 10 a la 9 átomos de carbono es decir
mil millones de átomos de carbono y por
acá tengo otra muestra distinta la cual
tiene 1 por 10 de las 6 de átomos de
carbono 1 por 10 de las 6 de átomos de
carbono lo cual es un millón de átomos
de carbono y bueno imagínate que nos
fijamos en un periodo muy corto de
tiempo imagínate un segundo este delta
de tm es un periodo infinitesimal es
decir muy pero muy pero muy pequeño de
tiempo pero imagínate que de temp es un
cambio en el tiempo y por lo tanto lo
vamos a tomar como delta de t y voy a
decir que este delta de t es un segundo
y lo que veo es que esta primera muestra
tiene un decaimiento de 1000
de mil partículas por segundo voy a
decir que esta primera muestra se decae
en mil partículas por segundo
y bueno date cuenta que esta muestra es
mil millones si te das cuenta ahora en
ese mismo periodo de tiempo esta muestra
que es más pequeña mi segunda muestra
solo tiene un millón de partículas por
lo tanto tiene una milésima parte de la
muestra es la izquierda o dicho de otra
manera podemos pensar que entonces
nosotros vamos a ver que es la cantidad
de partículas que van a decaer va a ser
también una milésima parte de la
cantidad que tenemos aquí es decir
solamente veríamos que una partícula por
segundo se decae en esta muestra de aquí
y bueno realmente estos datos no son los
datos exactos del carbono-14 y bueno
aunque no sabemos realmente cuál es esta
constante que tenemos aquí lo que sí
sabemos es que no importa cuál sea la
sustancia de la que estemos hablando
esta constante de aquí va a depender de
él
a sustancia es decir en el caso del
carbono-14 va a ser muy distinto al caso
del uranio y éste a su vez va a ser
distinto de radón y bueno lo que pasa es
que aquí vamos a tener cantidades
distintas porque depende de esta
substancia y de hecho es justo lo que
vamos a ver en el siguiente vídeo vamos
a calcular esta constante de aquí
dependiendo la vida media que nos den
pero lo importante de esto es lo que
quiero que te des cuenta es que esta
tasa de cambio realmente va a depender
de la cantidad de partículas que
tengamos y de hecho lo podemos ver desde
aquí arriba cuando nosotros tenemos una
vida media después de esta vida media lo
que vamos a hacer es perder la mitad de
la cantidad que anteriormente teníamos
si por ejemplo hubiéramos empezado aquí
con 100 partículas bueno pues aquí en
una vida media tendríamos 50 partículas
y después de dos vidas medias tendremos
25 partículas y lo que quiero que te des
cuenta es que de aquí para acá
perdimos 50 partículas y de aquí para
acá
solamente perdimos 25 partículas porque
depende de la cantidad que tenemos aquí
claramente se ve que la cantidad que
pierdes es proporcional a la cantidad
con la que iniciaste la cantidad depende
de la cantidad con la que iniciamos en
un periodo muy pequeño de tiempo y date
cuenta a lo que llegamos llegamos a esta
expresión de aquí la cual es una simple
o bueno tal vez no para todas las
personas sea simple pero es una ecuación
diferencial la cual podemos resolver
utilizando unos métodos muy sencillos
unas técnicas muy sencillas para
resolver este tipo de ecuaciones
diferenciales así que déjenme bajar un
poco en la pantalla y vamos a trabajar
con esta ecuación que tenemos aquí este
es un caso de separación de variables y
bueno que podemos hacer entonces para
resolverla lo primero que se me ocurre
es que podemos dividir todo entre n así
que vamos a dividir los dos lados de
esta ecuación entre n
y me quedaría un 1 entre n ok esto que
multiplica adn con respecto a de tema
voy a poner con este color lo voy a
poner con este color ok esto es igual a
menos el hambre y ahora qué te parece si
multiplicamos todo por de tema que me
quedaría bueno pues obtendría 1 entre n
esto que multiplica a de n esto va a ser
igual a menos lambda por de tema a menos
lambda que multiplica a de t de lujo y
bueno ahora me puedo tomar la integral
de ambos lados de esta ecuación la
integral de este lado la integral de
este lado y bueno entonces que nos queda
si yo me tomo la integral de uno entre
en tn
bueno pues pensemos en anti derivadas
como tenemos un integral indefinida
entonces pensemos en la anti derivada de
de la función uno entre n y eso es el
logaritmo natural de n así que lo voy a
poner así aquí tengo él
organismo natural ok en esta función
sale de esta integral ya esto le voy a
sumar
y déjenme tomarme este color a esto le
voy a sumar una constante de integración
la cual le voy a poner una constante 1
ok
mientras que del otro lado que me va a
quedar de resolver este integral de aquí
bueno pues si nosotros pensamos en anti
derivadas es muy fácil encontrar la anti
derivada de una constante lo único que
tenemos que hacer es poner esa constante
menos lambda ok y multiplicarla por la
variable bajo en la cual estamos
integrando la cual en este caso es el
tiempo menos lambda por el tiempo ok y
bueno como estamos integrando de aquí va
a salir otra constante a la cual le voy
a poner constante 2 y como tengo una
constante aquí y otra constante aquí que
no forzosamente es una misma entonces
qué te parece si mejor las pasamos de un
lado voy a pasar a esta constante
restando de este lado y así solamente
voy a obtener una constante y ahora sí
entonces
tenemos la solución de esta ecuación
diferencial justo por aquí aquí
llegaríamos bueno pues entonces puedo
decir que el logaritmo natural el
logaritmo natural de n esto va a ser
igual a quien a menos lambda te lo voy a
poner así a menos ok
lambda que multiplica al tiempo ok
más una constante 3 la cual obtenemos de
reducir estas dos constantes y ahora si
nosotros lo que queremos es la función
de n que depende de temp
bueno pues habrá que despejar de esta
ecuación de esta solución de esta
ecuación diferencial vamos a despejar a
n
que te parece si para despejar a n nos
tomamos la función inversa del logaritmo
natural y bueno la función inversa de
logaritmo natural nosotros sabemos que
es en la función exponencial así que voy
a elevar a la función exponencial cada
una de las partes de esta ecuación y me
va a quedar
elevado a esta potencia ok de este lado
mientras que desde otro lado voy a
obtener el elevado a esta otra potencia
ahora lo padre es que date cuenta que de
este lado am el logaritmo natural se
cancela con la función exponencial
porque son funciones inversas y
solamente me queda que en eem n es igual
y de este otro lado me queda el elevado
a la menos lambda t ok más c3 y lo bueno
es que tenemos una propiedad para los
exponentes y entonces nos quedaría que n
es igual a elevado a la menos la honda
teme a la lambda t que multiplican a
elevado a la c 3 ok que multiplica a
elevado a la c 3 estas dos expresiones
son iguales y ahora sí si bajamos un
poco más la pantalla ya no tengo espacio
por aquí voy a bajar un poco más la
pantalla y ahora si lo que quiero que te
des cuenta es que esta expresión que
tengo aquí es elevado a una constante
bueno pues eso realmente
otra constante así que no nos
complicamos la vida ya está constante
que tengo aquí le voy a poner un nombre
como esta es una constante arbitraria le
voy a poner el nombre de c-4 ds4 y
entonces ahora sí me va a quedar que
esta función que estaba buscando n que
depende del tiempo la cantidad de
sustancia que me va a quedar después de
un cierto tiempo esto va a ser
exactamente igual a esta constante s 4
ok que multiplica a el elevado a la
menos la cndh arte y esta es la solución
de nuestra ecuación diferencial ahora si
nosotros decimos que empezamos con una
cierta cantidad es decir que n de 0 con
la cantidad con la que empezamos es
igual a n sub zero voy a decir que esta
es mi cantidad con la que empezamos que
te parece si utilizando este dato
resolvemos para hacer 4 lo que voy a
hacer es sustituir 0 en esta ecuación y
me va a quedar que n de 0 ok lo cual
sabemos que es n 0 por lo que tenemos
aquí en el subíndice 0 esto
de igual hace 4 hace cuatro que
multiplica ha elevado a la y bueno
estamos en el tiempo cero por lo tanto
me va a quedar menos lambda por cero y
bueno menos lambda por 0 0 y me quedaría
elevado a la cero pero el elevado de
acero esto es 1 por lo tanto esto es
exactamente igual que ese 4 o dicho de
otra manera ya sabemos cuánto vale s4c 4
es la cantidad con la que empezamos y
utilizando esa información que acabamos
de obtener vamos a reescribir esta
ecuación que tengo aquí nos va a quedar
que n n de t ok es decir la cantidad de
partículas que tenemos en un tiempo dado
esto es exactamente igual que en el
subíndice 0 porque ese 4 es lo mismo que
en el subíndice 0 la cantidad con la que
empezamos que multiplica a la función
exponencial elevado a la menos lambda t
y bueno recuerda que aquí tenemos como
variable independiente al tiempo lo cual
nos va a ayudar a encontrar estas
constantes
ahora bien esto es justo lo que
queríamos pero si tú me preguntas de qué
me sirve esto si nosotros pensamos en la
vida media que te parece si intentamos
encontrar esta ecuación para el carbono
porque al final esto sirve para
cualquier sustancia que tenga un
decaimiento radioactivo si nosotros
hubiéramos de pura casualidad un signo
más aquí entonces estaríamos hablando de
crecimiento de la substancia pero con el
menos estamos hablando de decaimiento
radiactivo y entonces déjeme bajar un
poco más la pantalla porque ahora vamos
a trabajar con el carbono 14 nosotros
sabemos que el carbono 14 ok el carbono
14 cuyo número atómico es el 6 ok
este tiene una vida media tiene una vida
media tiene una vida media
el día de 5.700 años 5 mil 700 años ok y
como utilizamos este dato aquí en esta
ecuación y utilizando la vida media
bueno es que nosotros podemos decir que
si el tiempo es igual a cero si
empezamos supongamos que con 100 átomos
de carbono 14 entonces cuando nosotros
nos tomamos a n de 0 n de 0 estamos
hablando del tiempo igual a 0 cuando
empezamos bueno cuando empezamos tenemos
100 átomos de carbono 14 y ahora lo que
nos dice la vida media es que después n
de 5.700 años y ojo estoy cambiando la
unidad de tiempo ahora la unidad de
tiempo va a ser años para que esto sea
consistente hablando en años después de
5.700 años
bueno habrá pasado una vida media del
carbono 14
es decir llegaríamos a 50 y esto nos
quedaría igual con cualquier otra
cantidad que nosotros nos toman
podrían ser 100 átomos de carbono o 1000
átomos de carbono o x átomos de carbono
y entonces acá abajo tendríamos que
poner x entre 2 muy bien ahora
utilizamos esta información aquí en la
función que tenemos arriba estos datos
nos van a ayudar a obtener a lambda y
bueno lo primero que quiero que te des
cuenta es que ya sabemos cuánto vale en
el subíndice 0 nos quedaría esto de la
siguiente manera si ocupamos esta
información de kim ok me va a quedar que
en el tema n de t es igual a 100 a 100
porque recuerda que en el subíndice 0 es
la cantidad con la que empezamos 100 que
multiplica a m elevado a la menos lambda
t y vamos a intentar resolver para
encontrar el valor de lambda ahora hasta
aquí hemos utilizado solamente esta
información de esta primera igualdad si
nosotros queremos también usar esta vida
media entonces que nos va a quedar
nosotros sabemos de esta igualdad de
abajo que n de 5.700 años bueno pues
esto es igual a 50 esto utilizando esta
información que tenemos aquí que nos dan
en la vida media pero por otra parte
podemos sustituir este valor este valor
del tiempo aquí en esta ecuación que
tenemos arriba y me quedaría 100 que
multiplica
ok esto elevado a la menos lambda y en
esta ocasión el tiempo vale 5 mil 700
años por lo tanto la onda que multiplica
a 5.700 años y ahora lo que podemos
hacer con esta expresión que tenemos
aquí es resolver para obtener el valor
de lambda vamos a hacerlo déjame para
eso bajar un poco más esta pantalla
bajemos la pantalla y ahora sí si
nosotros queremos obtener el valor de
lambda
lo primero que se me ocurre es que
podemos dividir todo entre 100 y si
dividimos todo entre 100 voy a obtener
que un 50 entre 100 es lo mismo que un
medio un medio es lo mismo que e
elevado a la menos y lo voy a escribir
así 5.700 que multiplica a lambda lo
único que hice es voltear estos valores
y ahora para obtener este valor de
lambda voy a sacar el logaritmo natural
de ambos lados el logaritmo natural de
este lado y el logaritmo natural de este
otro lado y bueno aquí tengo el
logaritmo natural de un medio esto es
igual a el logaritmo natural de la
función exponencial elevada a la menos
5.700 lambda bueno pues eso solamente en
la parte de arriba menos 5.700 lambda ok
y ahora como lo que queremos es lambda
voy a decir que el abdi déjame ponerlo
así lambda es igual a el logaritmo
natural de un medio ok esto a su vez
dividido ok entre
menos 5.700 y bueno ahora si lo que
queremos saber es esto déjenme sacar por
aquí mi calculadora y la voy a traer por
acá y yo lo que quiero saber es cuánto
es
el logaritmo natural de un medio pero en
medios punto 5 ok esto esto a su vez
dividido entre menos menos 5.700 y esto
es exactamente igual que am 0.000 121 o
dicho de otra manera 1.21 por 10 a la
menos 4 déjame escribirlo así el valor
de lambda que nosotros estábamos
buscando es igual a 1.21 ok por 10
elevado a la menos 4 justo lo que
nosotros buscábamos y bueno ya que
encontramos el valor de lambda ahora sí
podemos escribir la ecuación que
nosotros buscábamos para el carbono 14
si nosotros queremos saber qué cantidad
de carbono
se va a ver en un periodo de tiempo
bueno pues esto es lo mismo que la
cantidad con la que iniciamos que
multiplica a m elevado a la menos lambda
es decir a la menos 1 punto 21 ok por 10
elevado a la menos 4 ok
todo esto multiplicado por el tiempo
esta es la ecuación para encontrar la
cantidad de carbono 14
a través del tiempo no solamente
pensando en una vida media ya podríamos
saber con esta ecuación cuánto carbono
14 va a haber después de medio año o
media vida media o tal vez 10 millones
de años o tal vez 10 minutos solamente
hay que tener cuidado porque en este
caso el tiempo está dado en años pero
bueno en el siguiente vídeo haremos
muchos problemas sobre este mismo tema